Really <laugh>.
I'm a meat eater. I'm a meat eater. I'm a meat eater. I'm a meat eater.
I'm a meat eater. I'm a meat eater. I'm.
A meat eater.
Plus I'm just gonna say that coming outta a man's mouth is one of the gay things
you could possibly say. Oh, that's worst things.
That what the whole hiphop lingo is like, what? Like what,
yo I with you hard, bro. That SU yeah, no you don't.
This is a mother to the imposter. You'd be all the imposter.
You every single round. That's sus yo, I with you. You yo,
I'm gonna make this wet. What the did you? They,
when they wet and when they kill someone and the t-shirt get wet,
they say that that's gay hip hop has the gayest lingo and they
don't like gay people. I'm like, wow.
Hi everyone. You, so what kind of music are you guys into these days? Just,
just curious. Well, I want you ask us, like, what is vegan music?
I actually got a real quick question.
What does y'all eat for breakfast this morning? What do you eat for breakfast?
<Laugh> they know how to bring back. As soon as she did, I went,
it's like, oh, people were really mean with Aaron and me bringing back.
You shut the up Jubilee. You know what the you doing? Just bacon.
Right? Cereal. Dairy milk. Um, no,
but I don't drink dairy milk. That's like, yeah.
Why don't you drink dairy milk though? Because I don't like dairy.
It's just gross to me. Yeah. Do you eat? Yes.
I'm a little bit confused about plant based versus vegan.
Cuz can there be meats that are plant based if I'm not mistaken?
I can I meat be plant based? No, unless it's foam meat.
Technically cow eats plants. Cows are plant based.
<laugh> that's yes. Yes. Don't even play with me. Don't even play with me.
This just reclassified or her divorce as plants.
I eat plants. Am I playing too? Sometimes do a bit of a vegetable. <laugh>
I mad at that. If you guys are enjoying today's video,
make sure you leave a like in a comment, help us out with that algorithm.
Push the video to everybody. That's how you can do it. Just smash it. Okay.
How do.
You like to cook your meat? Um.
I just got an air fryer so I can in there. Let it do its.
Thing. His name is Maui. He's vegan stop. We're good. Yeah. Cut. We're good.
Maui vegan long hair don't care. The white girls are not gonna last. No,
because there's just something about white girl veganism.
That just seems to go together. You know what I'm saying? It's like white girls,
veganism, astrology, and a Mandela tapestry. And on your walk also,
never forget your black lives matter sticker. Cuz white women love black people.
<Laugh>
I see everyone. I'm a little.
Confused.
What would giving people the impression that I was a vegan maybe in their head.
They're thinking like hipster, you know white girl. Oh,
you're gonna follow this thing. That's kind of popular. Yeah.
Uh that's exactly what I would expect. I'm not even going. I also vote you out.
Uh, one more time. Cause you say you don't eat dairy what's.
What's your reason they're going on the second white girl. Yeah. Yeah.
The why girl, number two. People are like man, black people meteors.
I really don't have a reason. I just prefer like O milk and everything.
Like my lattes and stuff like that. When it comes to milk, when it comes to.
What's the reasoning. Cause it's like, if you can have authentic, real milk,
like what's so bad about it. Rough.
Do you not know? Like 88% of people are lactose intolerant.
Nobody trying to have no real milk and I can liquid poop. I grew out of milk.
Yeah. It's just,
I grew out of milk and then cheese is fine,
but I grew out of milk and then I drink it again and it up mine insides.
<laugh> the poop that I did that day. Whoa, but you didn't poop. Poop, poop.
Got thought, guys, you didn't poop. He threw your butt. No, no,
my you didn't poop. You pee through your butt. No, I didn't poop. I didn't poop.
What? My pooped <laugh> no,
it was puking for my. Cause the CRAs that went with it, it was exact,
Hey the di a late then his frames a little late. But if you're eating right now,
stop watching.
You look very suspicious right now. You know what I mean?
And I noticed she started backtracking, you know, trying to offend herself. I.
Love oh milk. I was not gonna advertise that and look what happened. <laugh>.
And I wouldn't, if I was actually the more I wouldn't give myself out like that,
you know? Like, I don't know why.
Wow. That might be your strategy. You could say just.
A minute. I'm just saying a lot of people don't need dairy.
Even if they're not vegan,
like being vegan is a lot I've background that cuz I also have like almond milk
and oatmeal.
Like I'm saying the. I'm like, Hey, you gonna tell the truth. And he went, nah,
not me digging <laugh> he went, nah,
not me, man. Then I get me. I ain't going back to SA.
I think we should get on a different subject though. I need to, we should.
How did you cook your.
Chicken? Okay. I had Chi six chicken thighs stir, both sides,
pour broth and rice into it. Low and slow.
Low and slow six thighs just for you or like, yes,
I am crazy about chicken thighs.
Chicken's my favorite bro. Okay. I have a personal question. I,
how many times a day do you guys poop? Oh, at least twice, twice.
But I came in here actually had two nasty dudes and background.
Disrespect. My, I don't count. Yeah, me either at least twice.
Once in the morning, one foot.
One or two times. So I asked the poo.
Question because vegans have a healthier diet, healthy diet,
healthy digestive system, more healthy.
Poop, apparently healthy.
Don't that's they don't have a healthier diet. No,
but when you do have a healthy diet, you poop a lot more. Yes. But yes.
I see what you're saying. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. It's not because you're vegan vegan.
Let me just say you vegan for food while it can be fantastic.
There's also a lot of unhealthy options. They can later that with salt sugars,
all kinds of other ingredients that are not good for you. So just don't mistake,
veganism with being healthy.
Just because you're eating plants doesn't mean that all the stuff that you're
eating is inherently healthy because what you're adding in the dressings,
all that stuff matters to and oh, and uh, by the way,
vegan fast food is fast food.
It's gotta be Hillary. She flipping the script.
She don't want to answer questions. She don't like Barry it's clear as day. She,
the vegan.
Mia said that she tried to be vegan for a day, just for one day.
And she kind of looked like a vegan.
To me. I was gonna feel bad about saying the white girl for looked like a vegan.
And then she said, someone else looked like a vegan. I was like, no you <laugh>.
I think you going home.
She was managing the Q and a, but not answering any of the cues.
And she had like, uh, her fit was very, it gave bougie vegan.
You know what? This show DUL into stereotypes. Yeah.
That's what it really comes down to. That's what it judging. Yes.
I'm at all the votes and we have a tie.
The tie is between Hillary and Mia.
You have 30 seconds to deliberate and choose one person to eliminate.
We have 30 seconds to deliberate. Who's wider.
It. So Mia said she to be vegan. Why would want to try it again? Agrees.
I agree. Hundred percent. What?
You be too quick to keep changing the questions I'm also suspicious
of, but be.
A.
White. Little mama. Lemme whisper something in.
Tell you so about chicken. You my Le here.
Hey, tell you something.
My chicken, wait, just see my chicken. Hey.
My chicken and a like.
Hey, well how did we do that?
Waste time. What waste some time. Hopefully you guys like to ASMR today.
Make sure you like it. Subscribe.
Do you think she likes six times?
<Laugh> you think she likes six times Tommy just roasted.
They the death deliberate 20. The roast.
Yeah. Hillary. I'm sorry. You know what Hillary, you know you deserve better.
Okay. It, it just hit us up a bucket of chicken on us. We.
Got you. And the person eliminated this round is
Mia.
Sorry.
Miss that girl. I'm just an unhealthy person. I know M gives you protein,
but I have a very fast metabolism. This is,
which is why I eat six chicken thighs, um, in the evening.
And that's all you eat is just chicken thighs. I mean, I switch it up.
I get wings. I get chicken sandwiches. So all you eat is like meat then. Well.
Yeah.
Who just eats like chicken thighs and chicken thighs I chicken thighs.
There's a bunch of at home for targeted right now. He's like yo, yo, yo,
you yo this go better. Chill. Yeah. This is Booy hair vegan. Jenna.
Better chill. Yo yo get her off this stage right now. Yo yo yo Jenna, Jenna.
That's like going up to an Asian person.
Like who the eats ramen noodles all the time. Who eats rice all the time.
Rice <laugh> there's some people problems.
The satisfying feeling you get from just biting in to a
juicy chicken sandwich. The Popeye's chicken sandwich, for example,
just it's a wave of euphoria. It's very orgasms.
<laugh> let's circle back to Maui. Yeah. The vegan vibes defend yourself.
<laugh>.
You the vegan. Defend yourself.
Go <laugh> please just read that out.
Y are gonna be losing money. Sorry.
Please raise your hand. If you want to continue playing the game.
If the light turn green, that means you have voted out the mow and you win.
If the lights turn red,
that means the Mo is still in the box and you lose will the vegan please
step forward and reveal yourself in 3, 2, 1.
I know no
looking him feeling himself. Yeah. <laugh> woo. Shout out to, uh, the,
the, the meat shout out to Avan preach Jubilee.
Watch really?
I
wow. You apparently as have a, you know what I'm saying? So, you know,
shout out to as good job getting the dump. Cause you already know our fence.
Winners. Yeah. Winner, winner, dinner. Whoa, vegan,
chicken dinner. I got you. Asher winner winner, plant dinner.
Hey, well listen, shout out to Jubilee. That was enjoyable. Oh, that's funny.
You know what I'm saying? I'm not mad at it.
I know some people really get upset about veganism and stuff like that.
And I think the biggest thing is like,
people don't like it when shove down their face. Right. Everyone,
like you're murdering out. Like we get it. Okay. Shut up.
Was I personally really like food vegan food.
I've had it a lot of times when going out to restaurants, I think it's good.
There's some really good options out there.
So I don't poo in the diet and if people want to do it, do it go him.
And so I like the fact that he's not obnoxious about it. Indian is the,
the PO talked here. If you want Indian. Yeah. Indian food. Yeah.
Ethiopia food is talk. Yeah. In terms of vegan foods as well.
Yeah. This is great options. Oh, you know what else? All of you Haitian food.
<laugh> I can't even keep my coat fake. That.
What do you call a, what do you call a vegan? Haitian.
How do you call a vegan Thanksgiving? You don't call him <laugh>
that did. <laugh> that's it for today's video.
Hopefully you guys enjoyed it.
Were you guys able to guess the vegan from the jump?
Let us know and go check out the original video. If you want,
see the full video original.